michel legris rennais entre le monde
quand en 1956 bon vous êtes resté
combien d'années 16 ans et quelle
occupation d'un journal j'étais grand
reporter à dire les occupations
extrêmement variée est maintenu alors
donc vous avez travaillé dans le monde
et est dirigée par hubert beuve-méry et
vous avez travaillé donc dans le monde
dirigé par jacques pouget diriger si
l'on peut dire oui
bon alors donc vous objection votre
honneur je vous donnerai pas je me
donnait la parole après mme pour
répondre à votre tour maintenant
alors comme pour la ville est clair le
vous dites que le monde deux verbes
mairie était pratiqué l'objectivité
qu'est ce que vous appelez la
l'objectivité jeudi l'intention d'
objectivité l'objectivité n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut espérer
atteindre c'est quelque chose vers quoi
on se doit de tendre et en étant pas un
effort par une lutte contre ses propres
préjugés ses propres tendances ses
propres opinions
et c'est une recherche de l'exactitude
des fêtes de la justesse dans le
commentaire est au fond elle exprime
cette quête de l'objectivité un aspect
très important de l'information vous
dire que l'information est un des
visages de la connaissance et de la
connaissance de la vie quant au
contraire on dit que l'objectivité
n'existe pas lié à là quelque chose qui
devient extrêmement dangereux car on la
remplace par son contraire la
subjectivité et peut-être parfois toutes
les fantaisies individuelle alors parti
pris dans votre livre le monde tel qu'il
est on est vraiment pas tendre pour
aujourd'hui puisque vous parlez la joue
aussi vous parler d'erreur affirmations
fallacieuses des formations de fait à
situations abusives sauf s'ils se
dissimuler position tortueuse manca
bouffe les tartufferies mauvaise foi
journal as que lastic inquisiteur
logistique gens passaient alors vous
vous parlez d'une lune apparence non
objectivité d'apparence tel que vous le
résumer mon livre se résume ce serait ça
ramènerait une série d'imprécations mais
le vrai que ces mots qui s'y trouvaient
mais il se trouve juste il ya deux ans
aux téléspectateurs bien sûr mais alors
qu'est-ce qui vous a pas que ce soit
exact alors que vous appelez le gars de
ton était celui-là le monde aurait été
fondée à dire effectivement tu as été
livrés contre lui à des imprécations
non je crois que ces mots sont utilisés
au service d'une analyse et cette
analyse vise à traduire le sentiment que
beaucoup de lecteurs du monde ou
ressenti plus ou moins confusément
particulièrement les vieux lecteurs du
monde cela tout d'un coup ce sont bien
ne plus reconnaître leur journal encore
que le changement se soit produit de
façon subtile insidieuse et le monde
devenu mairie pour eux c'était quelque
chose absolument respectable il avait
foi en 8 confiance calmer et puis
aujourd'hui ils sont dorés journal qu'il
ait des routes qui les surprend et ce
malaise
il est réparti dans diverses catégories
professionnelles mais chacun croit qu'
il n'est victime du qu'il ya des erreurs
que dans la rubrique qui le concerne il
fut confiance aux autres rubriques
en fait cette attaque cet état d'esprit
qui est celui du monde aujourd'hui elle
répandus un peu dans toutes les colonnes
mais subtilement est situé sur un site
comme cet été vous alors que le monde
n'est pas perdre électeurs parce qu'il
détient
un double monopole un monopole de la
conscience qui s'est attribué le
monopole de la morale
ce monopole là est le plus vénérable
mais il détient aussi un monopole de
fait il est le seul journal de ce type
enfants aussi bien que vous avez un
nombre appréciable de nos lecteurs du
monde et surtout une qualité appréciable
les lecteurs du monde qui disent le
monde est le meilleur journal français
et lâche comme victorio je pense à lui
alors andré fontaine andré ferrand des
fontaines vous avez été sous le monde
d'hubert beuve-méry vous quelle fonction
eh bien j'ai été d'abord adjoint du chef
des informations générales ensuite j'ai
été reporter je comprends que j'étais
grand et puis ensuite j'ai été chef du
service étranger de 1951 1969 puis 260
là je suis un acteur en chef dans le
monde déjà couverts vous avez déclenché
alors donc vous êtes donc ça nous fait
combien d'années du monde
on ne commence à bien faire j'ai dû
entrer en 47 paul a donc bien alors
qu'est ce que vous avez entendu je viens
de dire michel legris je ne doute pas
que vous ayez lu son livre qu'à côté il
ya deux sujets dont j'aimerais parler
l'un c'est l'objectivité en général et
l'autre c'est le monde bon est-ce que
vous permettez je parle que j'en sois
près de l'objectif de prix alors je suis
très épuré en attendant le gris parler
de l'objectivité de l'effort de
l'objectivité se réclamer du monde de
buzz mairie et dénoncé le manque de
forme et parce que l'une des rengaines
je dirais devenir il était précisément
que l'objectivité n'existe pas nous est
toujours dit y'a pas d'objectivité il ya
une honnêteté je ne peux pas dire à quel
point je partage ces de vue pour
l'objectivité moi je paraphrase ray
volontiers un mot de rimbaud un très bon
mode rimbaud qui dit la contemplation la
justice le plaisir de dieu seul et de la
contemplation de la vérité c'est le
plaisir de dieu je n'ai pas le contraire
de quoi dit le contraire mais vous avez
parlé d' objectivité vous avez dit qu'il
fallait arriver l'objectivité encore une
fois comme sylvie lise landry je vous ai
déjà parlé j'ai fait une fois une
objection son donneur et puis après ça
je vous ai parlé tranquille alors vous
allez me laisser parler tranquillement
bon je parle de l'objectivité à part ça
vous aurez tout loisir de me contredire
si le coeur vous en alors je suis
concerne l'objectivité
il faut bien dire que suivant vous
regardez un objet c'est à tous viennent
mon objectivité de droite de gauche de
haut en bas le matin le soir si vous
êtes bible si vous êtes de myope si vous
n'êtes pas idiots et pas de la même
manière
et moi je reçois tous les jours des
lettres de lecteurs qui nous bien nous
félicitent de notre objectivité ou bien
critique notre manque d'objectivité mais
moi je vais vous dire le lecteur appel
objectifs ce qui est conforme à ses
propres préjugés et je pense que tous
les journalistes ici présents peuvent
confirmer cette année alors par
conséquent l'objectivité c'est une
hypocrisie chacun a sa propre formation
il ne peut pas en faire abstraction en
revanche ce qui existe et qui est fort
c'est important c'est l'honnêteté
je suis très content que vous sortiez ça
c'est ça va me prendre grand service
c'est l'honnêteté en traduction
française c'est plus facile de
l'utiliser c'est le sait le nez dans les
étoiles à knysna documents d'un bundle
qui dit dans son papier seulement le
pense et ce que dit de gris est alors en
ski
je vais vous le citez tout à l'heure je
vais vous montrer la conclusion j'ai là
dedans j'ai justement apporter pour ça
alors ainsi concerne en revanche
l'honnêteté l'honnêteté c'est l'état
d'esprit qui consiste lorsque l'on
constate que quelque chose n'est pas
conforme à vos préjugés car il n'y a pas
de gens qui n'est pas de préjugés tout
le monde en a et si le gris détestant le
monde c'est parce qu'il a des préjugés
de droite qui l'avait quand il était au
monde
bon et puis en a qui ont des préjugés de
bourges et puis c'est comme ça qu'il
voulut rien y changer puis c'est heureux
parce que ça pour qu'on ait la liberté
de le dire alors l'honnêteté ça consiste
justement à quand on rencontre quelque
chose qui contredit ce que don évident
la tête à se re met soi-même en question
et en tenir compte et moi ce que je peux
vous dire comme rédacteur en chef du
journal est ce qui fait tout de même ce
métier depuis sept ans de rédacteur en
chef c'est que je n'ai jamais vu un
rédacteur de notre journal à qui j'ai
dit ce que tu dis est ce que vous y en a
que je tutoie yens je vous vois est vrai
et n'est pas vrai je ne crois pas que ce
soit vrai qui est jamais remis en
question la nécessité de corriger ce qui
nous paraît de faux on peut se tromper
il faut se dire que nous imprimons tous
les jours cent mille mots ne sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte du nombre de
millions de mots que ça représente par
an et nous allons arriver bientôt à
dépasser le milliard de vaud depuis que
le journal le monde et sacré paquet bon
alors que si là dedans est avec ce
journal se fait essentiellement quatre
heures de tentes 8h30 du matin et didier
mais par définition on ne commettait pas
d'erreur croyant mais nous avons notre
originalité qui consiste d'abord à
rectifier les airs et ça nous faisons
toujours chaque fois qu'on nous signale
une erreur nous la rectif y compris
celle de monsieur soljenitsyne si on ne
parle de soljenitsyne tout à l'heure là
aussi de la documentation qui permettra
d'exercer droit de réponse comme ce que
julian nous a refusé lorsqu'il nous a
mis en cause lors d'une précédente
édition de la peau ce seront alors à non
un peu sauf voulait péter muros et dans
les dossiers de l'écran
sow vient ici et ces dossiers de l'écran
figurez vous vous pouvez rectifier
l'erreur
non mais là je vous hais
il est uniquement droit de réponse là
j'ai pas seulement de ce que je peux
après la balle après la posture fourie
d'une part vous avez parlé d'
objectivité et d'honnêteté mettons que
les deux mots sa voisine écoutez j'ai lu
cet article d'un journaliste américain
qui n'est pas n'importe lequel comme
vous avez l'air de le dire c'est un
journaliste du washington post
eh bien regardez article qui a fait
paraître dans la revue mort à propos
d'une monde au mois de mars 1976
que voulez-vous le traduire puisque
donnant normale dans le titre le monde
apparaît comme une des publications plus
intellectuellement malhonnête de la
plupart des journaux au financement et
on leur donne la conclusion du papier
malgré sa prospérité les nouveaux
talents apparus ces dernières années le
monde demeure idéologiquement très
semblable à ce qu'il était au moment de
sa fondation par hubert beuve méry en
1944 dans les pages du monde la
philosophie gaulliste d'une france
salvatrice du tiers-monde soustrait aux
deux géants capitalisme et communisme
est toujours bien vivante
vous passez votre livre a expliqué le
monde a changé de véripack monsieur nord
prenait comme témoin à charge vous
montre qu'il est demeuré idéologiquement
très semblable à ce qu'il était avant de
s'affronter alors un exemple un exemple
puisque le sortons des dossiers vous
venez de dire l instant que vous
contrôlez l'essentiel que vous n'avez
jamais vu un journaliste du monde
s'opposer à une remarque lui auriez fait
il faut donc penser que vous avez
souscrit à la relation du monde du monde
qu'il a donné des événements du cambodge
il ya un an et even relation clientèle à
laquelle fait allusion
quand même souligner que à propos du
monde
le journaliste du washington post
emploie emploie le mot crowcon le mémo
qui était employé dans les colonnes du
washington post à propos des nixon et de
la sphère du voiturier si jamais tu
oublies trois marques actuelles puisque
tout à l'heure j'ai commis une erreur à
propos de postroff je vous fais
remarquer cédric n'a pas paru non avec
une peine de mort est libre et monsieur
wendel était correspondre à paris mais
il ne l'est plus mais alors qu'est ce
que voulait dire voulez je vous cite sur
le cambodge
écoutez donnant puisque vous mettez en
cause dans votre groupe dumas du tout
s'ils visitent n'importe quel rédacteur
en chef averti est en mesure de renifler
que pareille dépêche et la dépêche de
patrice lemaire qui à paris le jour de
la prise de phnom penh où paris est
magique venant un peu vous nous aimez
les jeux vous me donnez les à celui né
décrivant l'enthousiame l'éthique l'aide
mais je vous le donnerai à près de chez
vous j'ai commencé à lire une de vos
phrases n'importe quel rédacteur en chef
à dire tu es toujours de renifler que
pareille dépêche
venant d'une ville où toutes les
communications sont coupées s'en tape
l'année la propagande ou la contre très
bien écrit ça bon alors imaginez vous
que cette dépêche est nu par l'ambassade
de france
donc il n'y avait ni contrainte ni
propagande c'est passer par le téléphone
de l'ambassade de france et des pêches
est arrivé à midi vous avez été
suffisamment longtemps au monde pour
savoir ce qu'on fait quand tu dépêche
arrive à midi et je vais vous dire ce
que manchester guardian qui n'est pas un
journal communiste
bon dit ça le reportage sur le cambodge
étaient une exclusivité mondiale
un jour après la chute de phnom penh
même s'il y avait une certaine naïveté
dans l'acceptation par le reporter de
démonstration extérieur d'enthousiasmé
populaire pour une armée de libération
aucun rédacteur en chef qui se respecte
n'aurait manqué de le publier à la une
et aucun lecteur doux et discernement
mais n'avait pas il n'y aurait trop
trouvé poursuit dans son paquet je ne
citerai plus la france a la chance
d'avoir le monde écoute et une société
si profondément conservatrice et à la
vérité si réactionnaire en nombreux
secteurs
puis deux jeunes étrangers demandent des
choses que son meilleur quotidien quand
j'a de l'autre côté michel le grillage
écoutez michel et lorsque la caméra
simplement filmer ça pour dire que quand
on dit que n'avons pas parlé
d'évacuation de la population
mardi en quels termes a eu lieu le
reportage et vous avez fait le temps de
vous renseigner
je vous en prie mais regardez à
l'évacuation d'une ville de deux
millions d'habitants
quel titre trouve-t-on dans le monde sur
les routes
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés
vous pensez pas peut parler de centaines
de milliers de réfugiés auraient été
arithmétiquement plus exact et
moralement plus juste à côté on arrête
là
normalement je vois du rhin piémont sur
le cambodge encore gala retransmis sur
tout le temps je peux vous dire que la n
8 a dit exactement un mois plus tard a
dit exactement la même chose que patrice
de berre il faut dire que monsieur
sauvagnargues d'affaires étrangers
interrogés le 15 mai sur ce qui se
passait au cambodge a dit nous n'avons
pour notre part aucune espèce
d'information sur les exactions les
atrocités au cambodge
nous pouvons ni confirmer ni infirmer
nous ne savons pas patrice jaubert était
à l'ambassade de france
quelques heures après la chute de mon
plein il est sorti dans le convoi il a
été deux pneus peine à la frontière
thaïlandaise
il a raconté ce qu'il a vu il ya eu très
peu d'ordre de récits de massacres à
l'époque
et parmi les récits de massat canin qui
a paru dans un journal en attaque n'est
pas représentée ici dont l'auteur a
démenti les termes quelques jours prend
la tête de l'eau alors c'est fini pour
le pôle cambodge n'ont joué sa voix
comme un joueur maintenant y'a quand
même un million de morts dans ce pays
sa joie sa valeur michel legris à
nouveau attribuer voir michel legré à
quoi attribuez vous ce manque là dessus
non non non non j'ai envie que je veux
pas savoir c'est alors à quoi nous s'il
vous plaît baril à quoi attribuez-vous
ces changements que vous observez dans
le monde en sont les raisons c'est jeter
les gens là bas comme le figaro le nom
l'argent à jouer un autre rôle au monde
mais je viendrai un peu plus tard alors
dépêchez-vous parce qu'on approchait il
y a eu je dédie à la qu'une substitution
une objectivité d'apparence à l'ancienne
intention d' objectivité et à
l'intérieur du monde des groupuscules
gauchistes des éléments gauchisant ont
peu à peu imposer une idéologie qui
finalement découle de l'origine
chrétiens du journal mais qui correspond
je l'expliqué dans mon livre une
christianisme dégénéré voilà en gros les
causes de la décadence morale du monde
ne pourrait parler même d'une certaine
déchéance spirituel alors si je
commençais la faute à la cité des
rédacteurs ont bien la société des
rédacteurs effectivement n'a pas fait
tout à fait son devoir
mais je pense que c'est non - la faute
de la direction et des dirigeants du
journal
ces sites ou une pour des raisons
diverses que j'explique également toutes
sortes de complaisance envers les
éléments qui peu à peu se mettaient à
travestir la vérité pour complaire à une
mode c'est à dire ils ont flatté
l'intelligentsia pas intelligence a
produit n'est pas dire que je n'avais
pas tellement l'attention de sortir ce
texte mais je trouvais ça processus de
revue un fab et qui avait paru en 1952
qui disait c'est lui parlant du
directeur de l'époque qui arrange les
textes autrement dit qu'il était fort
mais altère les tripes tout pour les
mettre au service d'une information
dirigé dans le sens qui convient au
parti pris adoptée par lui dans la
guerre froide
c'est lui qui tantôt par des
remaniements des coupures tantôt par les
titres ou les sous titres d'un à
caractère tendancieux rubrique etc
bon alors c'est qui ça eh ben c'est une
revue qui a peur que 152 5 les deux
bonnes minutes
alors imaginons qu'elle mais c'est très
difficile là je m'excuse de vous
interrompre à deux de répondre à un le
greek attaque fauves et on attaque en
baisse mais non jusqu'alors j'avais fait
la même gestion permettez nous est enfin
sur une petite diversion non je vais pas
d'hésitation mais parce que pour combler
notre émission émission qui a organisé
une harpie ou qui est extrêmement
importante parce qu'il est rare que les
lecteurs des journaux
entendre parler des problèmes de
pression c'est très très rare d'abord qu
on vous l'avait dit dans votre type
comme vous n'avez ni mousse qui vous
même les journaux n'aime pas parler de
leurs propres erreurs votre autre en
postant sur le sujet suivant les
journalistes l'argent et l'objectivité
or il faut bien regarder que ce soir le
journal pour l'objectivité est attaquée
est inquiet travers un livre qui a en
effet beaucoup de succès dont on a
beaucoup parlé et le journal dans lequel
l'argent joue le moins de grandes
moindre voilà ça c'est un problème alors
il à cela si vous permettez je
souhaiterais me reparler un petit peu
finale il a changé pas fini
choummaly falker je suis tout à fait
d'accord qu'on discute sont nos peines
et ferrals tous que continuèrent de
l'ufip
alors on est partis au ps dont
l'objectif de parvenir à ça mais je dis
ceci c'est que il est extrêmement
important que les téléspecteurs des
téléspectateurs sachent que l'argent
n'est pas le seul agent de non
objectivité dans la presse qu'il y en a
la presse que contrôler l'argent est
parfaitement alors moi ce que je veux
simplement dire quand j'ai lu votre book
je me suis demandé à quel genre
littéraire ça ressort fait c'est de la
paléontologie vèbre une vertèbre dans un
coin à un autre vers terre dans un
anneau avait fait un diplodocus bon et
vous avez conclu que le monde a changé
moi qui suis un vétéran du monde qui
était avant quand j'étais en prêt encore
presque à l'école maternelle bon eh bien
je vous dis ça toujours été pareil et
personne ne le sait mieux ici que
monsieur quittant l'année 1956 a pris la
direction d'un journal qui était dirigé
contre nous exactement dans le même état
d'esprit
c'est exact ça commence et moi nous
absolument pas c'est que ça fait
qu'est-ce qui vous écoutez écoutez moi
j'étais dans un journal qui s'appelle le
trop avoir l'amour du monde n'ont écouté
mon cher monsieur moi j'aime raconter
une petite histoire permettait le soir
où est sorti le premier numéro et sommes
pas revus j'ai été acheté le nom parce
qu'à ce moment là je ne retournais par
la rédaction
après midi à la vendeuse de journaux de
la place des thermes eu une vie de petit
pot est morte maintenant équipés
jules-simon monde que je t'ai temps de
parole qui forment paris journal
formidable ça va couler le monde en six
semaines vous dirai pas que c'est par
les inspecteurs de l'ue en cuir monsieur
je préparais le marchand
david une chose qui me suffit pas
jacente est ici parce que j'ai bien
pensé qu' on allait parler de ces choses
là j'ai importé ici les exemples des
exemplaires du temps de paris écoutez
vous n'allez pas faire croire aux gens
que c'est avec un journal qui avait
cette page une il avait appelé le temps
à fumer que le monde avait pris la place
du temple vieux monsieur fontaine
nous n'avons pas d'une copie jusqu en
matière de copie le monde avait tourné
la page intérieure voir un regard des
lois la double page du milieu regardez
là il ya des dames du ballon ovale et
l'avenue derrière les chinois veulent
pas écouter qu'à ça vient mais le top
voilà voilà
yannick et matthieu kamwa je peux vous
dire j'étais jeune à l'époque nous avons
pris la sortie de port stand caricom et
franchement aussi puisque françois a
dépensé plus d'argent pour se défendre
entre nouveau monde à l'échelle de gris
est-ce que je peux rester deux points
andre fontaine vous dites que le monde
de buzz mairie nous aliène rien dans
quelques jours à la rentrée
justement c'est pour ça que je voulais
ayant trait à l'époque et j'essaie de
claix journal je suis sorti le monde de
buzz mairie était un journal qui allait
à contre-courant
c'était un petit journal c'était un
journal pauvre le monde d'aujourd'hui
est un journal qui exercent une
influence considérable au point que l'on
ne peut peut-être pas trouvé de
publication en france qui ne subissent
peu ou prou son influence le monde
d'aujourd'hui est soumis à l'argent
d'une certaine manière ils trouvent dans
les bénéfices qu'il a fait sa
justification
quand on le critique il dit mou tirage
augmente je gagne de l'argent
et regardez le jugement que porte un
homme de gauche qui étudient mon livre
c'est le directeur d'esprit c'est john
nack
vous vous moquez lui ou deux mois ce pas
retrouver votre intonation bizarre
l'argent a joué au monde le rôle que lui
assigne égal dans la cité romaine
il a dissous la communauté elle a
remplacé par une juxtaposition de petits
groupes et david individualités les
suppléments pénible propagande au
service d'état souvent déshonoré par les
dictatures la torture l'exploitation se
trouve coisy imposé aux directeurs par
des rédacteurs que la fin des vaches
maigres à stimuler et qui trouvent leur
9ème degré je crois que vous avez choisi
dans le papier de dornach le passage aux
puits les plus faciles de parce
qu'imaginez vous j'ai vu deux hommes n'a
qu'une dizaine de jours il contestera
pas ce que je dis mais que je lui ai dit
ce que j'aurais d'abord il a attaqué les
salaires du monde je vais lui montrer
car il en avait fait état sans cette
carence est le plus au nord il a attaqué
nous fait une attaque excréments alors
je les montre et non c'est laid et il
m'a dit textuellement je crois qu'il ne
démentirait pas je croyais que vous
gagnez le double de ce que vous gagnez
le premier point deuxième point pic le
chiffre des personnes sur 7 tab à ce
moment là vont aligner les légions de
faire une surenchère dans la main je
suis chômeur faux signal qu'on vende ses
publics
tout est public au monde y compris les
salaires
le second point quand vous dites qu en
donne acte dit là aussi la réponse se
renseigner les suppléments imposé par
les rédacteurs à la direction c'est
totalement faux
la plupart du temps c'est notre manière
que ça se passe et la rédaction qui n'en
veut pas les suppléments et il ya
derrière moi deux ou trois personnes qui
peuvent en témoigner
car les micro ajustement bien sûr vous
dire après la rédaction dans l'ensemble
voit ça d'un mauvais oeil par conséquent
ce qui lie la dôme mac de bonne foi j'en
suis convaincue par ces camps sont
totalement bonne foi est totalement faux
bond